hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 1960 61 United States Chess
Championship which was held in New York
on the white end William Lombardi
playing against Bobby fiser this is game
25 from Fisher's famous book my 60
memorable games so let's dive in and see
what made this one
memorable the middle game features an
excellent
combination uh but beyond that phase the
endgame very instructive play in that
Final
Phase now on board we have an open
Sicilian Far and Away most popular for
white in this position is to address the
threat on e4 with Knight C3 right away
in this game it's F3 noted as the prince
variation what is its point and on the
surface note is that it defends E4
bigger picture however is that white
would like to control the D5 Square
white does not want to obstruct the C
Pawn
so white first plays C4 and only then
Knight C3 there's a fight over the D5
Square black would like to advance D5
frequently seen as a liberating advance
for team black the prince variation is
saying not so fast let's get some more
development in in this position black
castles if black tries D5 while the king
is still on home base it's not good for
black white can for instance capture
with the c pawn and deploy the bishop to
B5 pinning the Knight so before D5 is
even a thought it's
castles now black is ready to go with D5
white however says not so fast this
retreat has unmasked the queen to defend
D5 white now has how many on this Square
four and if black tries D5 here there
are only three supporters so black
doesn't have
enough how do you get D5 in then how do
you support this D5 move once more well
you don't fer plays it anyway as a
Gambit this is considered the best move
and I imagine in general moves like this
have some psychological impact on an
opponent I mean white has played many
moves played A variation that is
designed to prevent this very move yeah
it's still
played where is Black's compensation for
this Gambit is giving up the pawn here
black has a lead in development and I
imagine black also plays a move like
this with an eye on the white king who's
still too tempy out from
castles so let's see how we continue
here white takes with a
piece uh if instead it's a pawn capture
a good follow up is Knight B4 targeting
D5 and do know with the pawn capture the
E files completely open so right around
the corner Rook E8 is likely an
excellent move in this one though it's
the peace captures on
D5 and the queen exchange is
declined black anticipates a valuable
Tempo one way or another on the queen in
this position it's Queen B5 considered
one of the top moves is Bishop E2 a step
away then from kingside castles in this
one though it's Queen B5 and now Bishop
D7 lining up a discovered attack after
the Knight moves white ignores this
playing Rook C1 so this is now the start
of an excellent middle game
combination Fisher's next move is Knight
B4 now B4 you could play Knight B4 you
have to see several moves deep
eventually Fischer is going to find
himself in a position where there is
only one move that keeps an advantage
for black everything else and white
would be completely
winning now this last move what's
happening there's a problem on C2 two
attackers the queen is hit A2 is hit in
the game Knight takes Knight
follows if Queen C4 is played here
covering uh all these different threats
uh Queen A5 is an excellent reply
setting up a discovered check and also
Paving the way for more development
another Tempo against the
queen in this one it is Knight takes
Knight Queen takes Rook check and only
then do we have the capture on
B5 in the game it's Knight D5 here if
the bishop takes on B5 no problems here
for black we simply take the Knight with
check black is up the exchange white has
a pawn for it but black is up the
exchange here is the
position after Knight D5 that fiser had
to see very clearly before playing
Knight B4 this is where black now has
only one move that keeps an advantage I
wonder if you can spot it feel free to
pause the
video okay in the game it is Bishop H4
check
this is a move Fisher in his book
described as the scorpions sting at the
tail end of the
combination why is this the only move
that keeps an advantage for black well
what other options are there if you try
and save the bishop you lose this bishop
and these two miners outweigh the
rook and if you take on F1 white doesn't
take on F1 he first inserts this in
between move Knight takes Bishop check
and only then Scoops up the bishop yet
again the miners outweigh the
Rook so essentially this bishop H4 check
is not allowing white to take a piece
with check that detail clearly
matters play follows with
G3 only now do we have Bishop takes on
F1 King takes bishop and now we have
time to rescue the bishop black is
better how to proceed here in this end
game the Knight is a very strong piece
first things first though let's get some
developing moves in here the bishop is
maneuvering just in the nick of time to
C3 not allowing this Rook entry on ranks
two rank one
from here F5 in general being up this
extra Rook more open files the better
for black so he's
welcoming a pawn exchange to rip open
another file white says I want to keep
things a bit
closed the downside here for white is
that the Knight is now without defense
and it is now immediately
challenged in this position it's Knight
B4 what other options does the Knight
have could go to E3 or
F4 uh I want to just touch on these
these two moves here briefly if Knight
E3 you can pretty much discount playing
a move like Knight to E3 because black
would have F4 and this Fork will crack
open a
file if you try Knight F4 uh it's a bit
tricky I feel like this might have been
the uh better move for white to go with
it's not so easy to break down White's
position which is a fork threat it
suggests Rook E8 and then some play on
The Queen side to try and dislodge this
strong Bishop
Post in this one though it is Knight B4
and this allows a minor piece exchange
kicking off with Bishop
A5 A3 and Bishop takes Knight in the
game it's Pawn takes
Bishop this may seem appealing taking
with the bishop Landing a skewer but
black has a way out with a
check so it's Pon takes and we get some
peace improvements here in this ending
Kings both improve the Rooks get to I
guess the very best squares the black
Rooks I'm speaking of this one is a
passive Rook now in this position white
continues with rookie one and black is
now
winning can you find Fisher winning
combination feel free to pause the video
okay when you're up some material you
should always be looking for ways to
give it back and still emerge the better
side black has a perfect opportunity
right here and that is to take the
bishop with check take the pawn with
check take the rook and this is now a
winning King and pawn ending why well
the black king takes up this wonderful
post on
C4 but here's the detail the big point
in this King and pawn
ending an outside past Rook Pawn is King
with
B6 we're supporting now
A5 Black's going to have a passed Rook
Pawn so how does this play out after
King
C2 there's some play on the king side
with G5 it's not necessary black can
already push with the a pawn but he goes
with the G Pawn First and still doesn't
play A5 here he plays F4 so a little
note on this move uh it's not a
requirement to play F4 but I think it
goes to show the mentality of of fiser
in a way uh he's trying to still be
precise in this King and pawn ending
even in a position where Precision isn't
a requirement he could still win right
away by pushing the
Aon why is he going with F4 rather than
G4 I think it's because you would like
to fix this Pawn as a Target since it's
closer to the black king so only after
fixing the F Pawn does he now bolt with
the a pawn and what's going to happen
the white king is pulled away to the
edge he is now outflanked by the black
king and black is able to Simply scoop
up all of these pawns now on the king's
side it's at this point that white
simply
resigns if the game continues black and
simply win every Pawn if he wants to and
of course this is completely winning but
this one goes no further after move 43
King E3 Lombardi
resigns so what' you think of this one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care
bye